افاد مراسل الجزيره باندلاع اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله في بيت لاهيا
شمال قطاع غزه واكد وقوع اشتباكات ضاريه
شرق منطقه دير البلح والمغازي وسط القطع
واظهرت صور خاصه بشبكه الجزيره تواصل
اطلاق النار واشتباكات ضاريه في محيط
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بدير البلح وسط قطاع
غزه وقد سمع صوت اطلاق نار كثيف وذوي
انفجار ضخم
المنطقه الاطلاق قنابل
ناعه محيط مستشفى شهداء
[موسيقى]
الاقصى اطلاع قنابل الناره
بالتزامن قصف مدفع عنيف في محيط المستشفى
واطلاق نار من اليات الاحتلال
متوغل على شارع صلاح الدين
بالقرب بمدخل قريه
المصدر نستمع صوات الاق نار من
الاليات الاق نار كثيف
[موسيقى]
جدا
اشتباكات واطلاق نض كثيف من دبابات ولايه
الاحتلال هنا على شر صلاح الدين في محيط
مستفى
[موسيقى]
الاصن يعني لا نعلم التحديد اين هديه
الاشتباكات واين تقع بالضبط لكن هي
بالغالب شرق شارع صلاح الدين في دير البلح
لكن يسمع دويها بصوت عالي وكبير هنا بداخل
مستشفى شهداء
الاص مروحيات لجيش الاحتلال تقوم بتمشيط
المنطقه واطلاق النار بين الحين
والاخر المروحيه تحديده في منطقه
المصدر في شرق دير البلح
يعني اطلاق النار
مستمر
مستمره تطلع يحلق بشكل كبير جدا بشكل
منخفض في محيط
المستشفى
[موسيقى]
اطلاق النار
مستمر الر محيط
[موسيقى]
المستشفى